両ソロ肇社長です神の義をちょっといじろうと思います
はい芝だけで本当髪の毛や何もしてなくて
左右茶色かったんですけどどんどん黒い土が伸びてきて自分で自分に切っちゃうから
まばらになるんです
今まばらなんですよ今日は
利用して言ってるこの髪型はねこの髪型でこの髪色でちょっと
ん
以上だと思います男はハゲるとかも決まっています彼の頭頂部が前通るここかここから
来ます
後は男性ホルモンが関係していてここと後ろは女性ホルモンが関係してるって
男を上げるとしたらここがここにいきますので僕の今日の作成はここぞここを染めずに
ここらへんとかここらへんとがなんか部分的に染める
れたらいいなって思います
ちょっと僕までちょっと朝来を気にしてるんですよだから今日
美容師さんでもねガッツガッツとね俺などバインドもう
沈んじゃったわけですもうピュアさに負けないようにもう俺の意見を全部言いますみな
さーん
じゃ行ってきます盲腸は本当に活躍ますちょっとられた瞬間加瀬離婚できますかね見て
よ
ん
なんか web かんだめっ
と2工区をぽく見えるですけれども
こっち側ですこっち側をもうここらへんも全部金利してもらいました
案内ではあんな a さんの明るくないよ後ろもこんな感じです
自分でやってないからね中古でこれにこのヤンキーの顔とね
真面目な人の猫に銘じよ松尾ともに僕はなったんで
もうず明るくても良かったかなっていう気で髪の毛はそれだって撃つ動画でした
ん
ana
me
何分
んん
me